hey everybody
i'm going to put up a video from my
colleague and friend jonathan pagio a
russian orthodox icon carver a great
artist and a very profound thinker in my
estimation
about a month ago so that would be
october of 2021
i listened to a lecture he gave to the
montreal young society
on the conceptual structure of genesis
and i thought it was brilliant it was
like 20 years of thought packed into an
hour of lecture and then also a
brilliant q a that followed analyzing
some iconic images in the russian
orthodox tradition and i thought that it
would make an excellent adjunct to my
biblical series on genesis coming at it
from the different tact that jonathan
takes
elucidating the ideas that i had
developed and certainly the ideas that
he has developed i always learn a lot
from listening to jonathan and so i
reached out to him and the young society
of montreal which kind of gave us
permission to repost the lecture and he
agreed to do it and my production team
has been working on it and so we're
pleased to bring it to you and i hope
that you enjoy it even more or at least
as much as you enjoyed the
genesis lectures from a few years ago
and hopefully there's more of this sort
of thing to come
hi everybody my name is david andrea i'm
a college teacher in montreal it's my
pleasure today to introduce jonathan
pajot who i see as one of a small
handful of cultural commentators helping
us make sense of our strange historical
moment
i first came across pajo in 2017 in the
chaos and contestation of that time
the mood of rebellion was especially
pervasive on the internet with the memes
of 4chan's edgelords fueling the triumph
of trump and brexit
we all remember those years not too long
ago
and jordan peterson hosted jonathan
pagio on his youtube channel to talk
about what they called the metaphysics
of pepe
pepe of course was that cartoon frog
that seemed to symbolize the worst
instincts of the alt-right
or maybe just the timeless urge of the
jester to poke at the sanctimony of the
powerful
peterson and pajo's discussion seemed to
move beyond the tawdry politics of the
moment and grasp something deeper going
on
so like many people at that time i
decided to keep an eye on this
interesting new commentator
a little bit later pajo organized a
documentary screening on jordan peterson
that was held here in montreal so i saw
that name pop up again oh i think i've
heard of that fellow
you may know
that pajo is a carver by profession he
is an editor at the orthodox arts
journal
today i see him mainly as a youtube
commentator
and in that medium i see him occupying a
role somewhere between an intellectual a
social critic and can i say an
entertainer
he speaks with a series of interlocutors
amongst them of course jordan peterson
uh christian commentators like paul
vander clay
secular psychologists like john verviki
of the university of toronto very
interesting fellow
novelist vesper stamper
these are a few of the guests he's had
on who stick out for me
some recent topics that pajo has
discussed include universal history this
kind of retro idea of a grand narrative
that includes and makes sense of
everything
right with of course a christian
foundation
the interpretation of scripture but also
symbolism within pop culture he seems to
be fascinated by superhero movies and tv
shows as well as rap stars like lil nas
x and kanye west
and i confess that i share that last
fascination
throughout all of this as pajo says
symbolism happens
so today it is my great pleasure to
introduce him and i'm hoping that he
will lay out a road map to the symbolism
which is happening today and which maybe
is gathering for the near future
well hello everybody
thank you for inviting me this is a
really wonderful opportunity
i'm surprised to see some people that i
know in the i'm kind of looking at the
mosaic here of everybody not everybody
but some people so i'm surprising some
people that i know and then some people
that i don't know
um
and so what i want to do with you today
is i want to kind of take you on a
symbolic trip
the
i want to present to you first of all
the let's say the source of the
symbolism that i tried to present
the frame you could say of the symbolism
i'm going to present it maybe in a
little more of a
a little more of a technical way that i
usually do in the in the more kind of
colloquial way that i do on youtube um
so hopefully that'll be okay and then
what i'll do is i'll take you on an
example
of this symbolic pattern uh
a very basic example which is we're
going to read the first chapter of
genesis together and we're going to try
to look at how
it kind of manifests
the symbolic pattern
and how this becomes a kind of map
that you can use to interpret the world
but also map especially a map that you
can use to inhabit your life
and so we'll see that symbolism is not
also not only about interpretation i
mean as unions you know that it's a way
to be in a way to kind of inhabit the
world
and so there's an interesting moment
right now i think in the zeitgeist in
the culture
uh something like the end of materialism
or the end of physicalism we saw of
course i think that that jordan peterson
has played a big role
in poking at this you know kind of
poking out the new atheist this last
weird new atheist moment that we had uh
in the early 2000s
um
and so what we're seeing is
kind of materialism running to its end
and it is happening in physics with the
problem with the observer it's happening
in things like like just this notion of
complexity or complexity theory the
problem of emergence
all of these things are
bringing materialism to its end and the
way that i like to to understand it is
that
for a while we had this kind of weird
duality of mind and body or mind and
matter where
we kind of abstracted the mind into this
place that we didn't talk about and then
we look at the world and we interpret
reality and as materialism kind of ran
its course as this kind of scientism ran
its course at some point
you could say there is something of a
little moment a surprising moment of
pride where
as we're kind of
exhausting the things that we study
people realize that
well there's this one thing that we
haven't studied it's
the thing that's looking at everything
else like
we're studying the world the world the
world but all of a sudden we realize
that there's a viewer that's doing that
studying
and as soon as the materialist eye you
could say turned towards the viewer
turned towards the interpreter turned
towards trying to understand
consciousness trying to understand
meaning itself then things become very
loopy uh and certain
the simplicity of the dualistic model
stops to make sense and this happens
very much in terms of evolutionary
thinking what evolutionary thinking is
did in some parts is try to explain the
motivations of humans
but when you start to do that you have a
problem because this human who's talking
about
evolution is the what you're trying to
interpret so you're actually
interpreting the interpreter and so what
has happened is that
it's opened the door to all kinds of
questions the problem of emergence the
problem of quality
and one of the big things that's
happened is the problem of attention
and this has been manifesting itself on
in different fields
uh
and it's realizing that the world is too
complex
that the world actually is kind of
indefinite in its complexity you know
everything you look at everything you
encounter has an indefinite amount of
complexity and it's made of parts and
those parts also have an indefinite
amount of complexity and you can just
scale that down you know to the quantum
field or whatever
and
many thinkers realize how is it that
how does this work how do things scale
up
between different levels of phenomena is
how is it that i can look at a chair and
see that the chair is both one thing
it's a chair but it also is many things
and those many things are also many
things but i can perceive at every level
of reality
that there's unity so i can notice a leg
of a chair and i can notice the color of
the chair but i can also see that all of
this participates in with in the being
of the chair
and this is like a hard problem it's a
it's a it's a difficult problem because
it ends up being
it ends up infecting all of meaning
making and in in fact science and in
fact it's not an infection it's a it's
actually a kind of healing i think but
it kind of seeps back into science and
sees back into
um
back into uh the very way in which we
understand the world and we realize that
we'd have difficulty accounting for the
qualities of things using
descriptive means
that we have difficulty even accounting
for the identity of things using
descriptive means
so once we have the identity we can
describe things but the identity seems
to
to kind of emerge from somewhere else or
come from somewhere else it kind of
brings multiplicity into unity and so
what's fascinating is that
it has like i said it has opened up all
of a sudden the possibility for people
to kind of to
understand ancient thinking
in a way that until recently it was very
difficult to understand
and so if we understand for example we
realize that the world has to be
patterned
that there has to be patterns in the
world and this is more than just a
psychological
uh reality it's not just about
describing the psyche of the human
person it's actually a descript a
cosmological argument it's an argument
about how reality works which is that
for things to exist they have to be
patterned and those patterns seems to
seem to stack up
at different levels of reality
and also seem to exist in
smaller patterns seems to exist in
bigger patterns right i mean you can
think about it physically or think about
it any way you want
and this actually seems to be
something which is inevitable for us to
be able to even encounter the world
now what that means is that it brings
back the idea of intelligence the idea
of consciousness and it can reconnect us
to
how the ancients talked about it some
people are talking about something like
the revenge of aristotle right or the
revenge of plato
because suddenly when we talk when we
we have to re-enter our experience and
try to analyze our experience
we realize that oh actually when
aristotle talked about potentiality and
actuality
i experience that every single day of my
life
right i actually encounter the field
that presents itself to me
as
potential which is brought into
patterns brought into actualities that
that i need in order to be able to exist
right and those actualities those
patterns
they're not just uh
they're not just mathematical patterns
or ideas in the in the vague platonic
sense that people have but they're
actually teleological their purposes
right and these purposes they can be
regained from
evolutionary thinking which is just the
strangest thing in the world like who
would have thought that darwin would
bring plato back but when we re-enter
evolutionary thinking we realize that we
need purposes in order to encounter the
world
so so it's like if i if i
this cup the fact that i recognize it as
a cup is because i recognize its purpose
its purpose to me as a human being
uh and that actually scales the
hierarchy of of purposes
even in terms of science right people
think that science is is just a study of
phenomena but we we always forget that
science is embedded into us into social
systems
and that for example the science that
will get the most attention will always
be the science that is the most
fascinating or useful for humans and the
scientists that would get the least
attention which means the least money
the least uh effort to study will be the
things that are the least useful for
humans so as soon as you re-embed
science into its actual social frame
then all of a sudden
this hierarchy just reappears again this
ancient hierarchy which is basically you
could call it something like the
religious the religious hierarchy
so what it does is
that these patterns these teleological
patterns these patterns with purpose
come back into
the way in which we
actually exist in the world so you can
understand that
ritual
suddenly makes sense again not only does
it make sense but it's actually
inevitable
and you can see
everything you do
through ritual
because everything you do in the world
is pattern teleologically
it's patterned towards purpose
and when it and sometimes let's say
there are moments in which that purpose
will kind of break down but that is also
part of the that's a great ritual which
usually involves something like carnival
which involves aspects of chaos on the
edges of these patterns
and so if you if
so you realize that like drinking a cup
of water is necessarily ritualized it
has to be teleological and it has to
have a certain form i have to do certain
things in a certain order in order for
me to be able to achieve the purpose
that i'm reaching
with my
with my with my cup
now bring this into the human sphere
it's the same when i encounter someone
my encounter necessarily
has to be ritualized and you can realize
that it has to be ritualized because if
you try to do the opposite of the ritual
you're gonna get some funny reactions
right try to talk to the back of
someone's head for example for a while
or just lay down in the on the middle of
the ground while you're speaking to
someone and you'll realize that that
that human relationships are extremely
ritualized right we speak and we and we
feel the tension right so you feel like
a rubber band you speak and then you
have to stop speaking and you have to
listen and so there's this kind of wave
this back and forth wave this this call
and response you could call it that
happens in a conversation that if you
don't follow that pattern you're gonna
break the relationship and no one's
going to want to talk to you anymore and
everybody knows someone like that and
everybody sometimes has fallen into that
excess
where they've talked too much and they
realize it or they haven't talked enough
they just listen and didn't give their
opinion and the other person feels like
you weren't there so we can see that
this is how it works now
you can scale this pattern up
from
simple human interactions from simple
human engagement with objects
into social interactions as well
that is we realize that
in order to have teleology in order to
have purpose and in order for a group to
have purpose it has to encounter itself
ritually
it has to have things which bind it
together
which make it make the group recognize
that it is
act it is together because
this is the the problem of multiplicity
and the problem of complexity happens
especially in terms of human
interactions
what's the difference between a group
and a crowd
what's the difference between a team and
a crowd right there are a bunch of
people
that are together
but one of them is not bound
teleologically and the other is right a
team is bound teleologically it's a
soccer team they are bound towards a
purpose they're bound towards a common a
common identity and that common identity
will manifest itself
in ritual
and the ritual include those rituals
include the rules of the game the rules
of engagement those rituals also
includes other things which are more
related to identity and this is
something which will bring us
straight into religious ritual that is
those rituals include the capacity
to attend
to the thing that binds us together
and this is when we're going to start to
realize that this pattern
is
almost first and foremost the pattern of
attention or the manner in which we're
capable of paying attention
and so a team will have to attend to
those things that bind them together and
what that will look like will be
something like celebration
you know
at the fear of sounding somewhat
scandalous to people it's going to look
something like worship like a little
worship
right it's going to be a celebration of
the thing which binds us together
reverence towards the thing that brian
binds us together i don't want to i use
the word worship to scandalize you a
little bit but like reverence is fine
right and so they will have to reverence
their team colors they have to reverence
their team name they have to have a
totem a mascot which will represent them
in a mythological with the mythological
frame as a kind of
an animal or some some figure that has
more social connotation that will bind
their identity together
and then they will also be bound you'd
say on the human level through a person
who will represent their ideal the team
captain the coach at different levels in
the in this kind of hierarchy of being
and so you will see that
a sports team but not a support seem a
knitting group or anything that is bound
together
we'll necessarily have to have these
elements at different levels
of of of uh of reality now
one of the aspects is that it will also
have to judge
what is inside and what is outside
and what will be the judge of that
inside and outside will be their reason
for existing
right and so you could say the logo
something is a christian term the logos
of the group will
be that which binds together which joins
the body
into one
but will also be that with judges those
that are inside to bind them but also to
exclude them
and so think of a knitting group for
example right you have a knitting group
a bunch of people come together they
knit together that's what they do and so
there's a ritualized reality to that
which is that when they meet they're
going to knit now as they're knitting
they'll probably do other things as well
well they'll talk they'll chat they'll
talk about their lives they might you
know someone might bring something to
eat and this is all going to kind of
organically participate in the knitting
group but let's say that at some point
someone comes and says well you know oh
i like this knitting group i like to
move this knitting group but i don't
want to to knit i want to play music
and so they're like okay well maybe one
person playing music while we're
knitting is not a big deal and so you
know they play music and then that
person invites someone else and says i
like this knitting group but this music
playing is pretty cool so what if i
brought my instrument and then we start
playing music so imagine now that
process going on to a point where
well okay are we a knitting group are we
a band like what's going on we have to
decide we have to judge
either we exclude these musicians or
exclude their practice or we cease being
what we are we die basically this
knitting group is going to cease to
exist it's going to be transformed into
something else okay um
and so this is this is how
kind of this pattern acts as the
attention that we give towards the
teleology of the group will also act
the logos of that the reason the purpose
that i'm looking at will look like a
binding agent but will also look like uh
like a judge
um and so like i said that this is how
all
kind of uh reality works or all of how
reality lays itself out and so
what i want to do is i want to
kind of show you that this this pattern
that i'm talking about is really just it
is a cosmological argument it's an
argument about how reality works
and what it what it does is that it
argues about how reality works based on
the notion that intelligence
is necessary for reality to unfold
and so this is something which is kind
of bubbling up right it's not something
which is that everybody agrees with in
in in the world but it's something which
is bubbling up and we're seeing appear
in different fields as even in science
we're we're finding some physicists who
are arguing what they call uh the strong
antropic principle which is that
consciousness or intelligence
is necessary for
the for the world to unfold because
intelligence is the only thing which is
able to discern
pattern and not just discern but it's
like a it's not just a discernment it's
a participation in pattern
right because the agent
the the pattern ends up coagulating in
the agent you could say
and so the the conscious being
sees these patterns but also engages
with these patterns and transforms these
patterns it's not just a it's not just a
passive uh can i say it's not just a
passive uh uh relationship to to the
world it's an active embodied
relationship to the world
okay now
before i give you before we go on the
example i want to say that this
once you kind of enter into this way of
thinking it has certain consequences
and and one of the consequences is that
the intelligent perception the
perception of the embodied intelligence
becomes the primary
mode of engagement and interpretation in
the world
and what i'm saying this this is
extremely important because we tend to
abstract and become scientists
and we think that that is the primary
way to interpret reality
right and we do it we all do it we
analyze we're analysts we we we look at
the pattern from outside right we we try
to stand above and say well look at that
interesting pattern in that culture look
at that interesting pattern in that
culture and look at how nice it is that
they're the same and we're kind of like
these disembodied uh beings that are
just looking at the world supposedly but
once you realize that once you realize
this notion that intelligence is
necessary
and this ritualized embodied reality is
necessary for the world to appear
then it changes everything
because you have to embody
you have the real way to engage the
world is the embodied way so it's not
that we're standing above the stories
and we're interpreting the stories it's
not that we're standing above the images
and we're interpreting the images
we are in a story
we participate in a story we participate
in communities we participate in images
right they are our communities they are
our images they are our
uh
they are
they are the things that make us exist
right as we kind of actively engage with
them
um and so so that's why if you
if you look at the way that you know
when uh when david at the beginning said
that jonathan is an artist this is
extremely important
in my theory about reality is that it's
not it's like i'm presenting it to you
in a way in a theory but this
presentation that i'm giving you this is
secondary to what is really going on
what is really going on is that to the
mo to the extent that i'm capable of
i get up i get up in the morning and i
physically carve sacred images right i
go to church on sunday and i physically
participate in the rituals and the
liturgy
you know i sit there with my family
around the table and i eat a meal and i
realize that this meal is re is is a
smaller version of the ritual that i'm
engaging in on sunday morning with with
my parish and so it's a it's an embodied
it's an embodied reality it's an
embodied uh engagement with the world um
and so
so like i said it's it's a pretty
radical it's very radical and sometimes
people don't realize how radical the
proposition i'm making is the the
proposition i'm making is is that if
what the things i said are true
that means that the the only way for
them to be fully true is for us to dive
in and embody
uh while realizing of course and while
being aware of all the problems that
come with this pattern as well there are
many problems which come with this
pattern because i said right one of the
issues of the
the reality of being engaged in a group
that has a teleology that has a purpose
is that it excludes that's the very
nature of a group a group excludes
groups always exclude
that's why they're a group because
they're not the totality of all
manifestation in the universe they
necessarily need to exclude
you know i mean
even if you want to be inclusive in the
kind of uh
the kind of
let's say a politically correct way
you're still going to exclude animals
from your group or you're still going to
exclude rocks from your group you
necessarily have to exclude because
you're not god right you're not the
totality of everything in order to kind
of move teleologically in the world you
have to to exclude and so that has a
prop that has difficulty to it and so
but there are ways to kind of let's say
to deal with those in a manner which
won't make the group completely uh
self-devouring um
and also won't make you kind of fall
into the chaos of thinking that just
that nothing has identity and everything
is just a mush of potential let's say
okay so hopefully if that's clear what i
want to do is i'm going to go into
the the first chapter of genesis and
show you how the creation
narrative it's a very very wide story
it's a very very it's a huge narrative
obviously i can't exhaust it but i want
to show you is that the manner in which
it shows
that the world manifests itself through
intelligence through consciousness
and that this is actually the agent
of
how reality comes together uh and how we
participate in that uh as intelligent
beings okay
um
and so hopefully you are little aware i
will go through the verses but i mean
i'm not going i hope everybody's a
little bit aware of the creation
narrative in genesis
enough that that you'll be able to at
least follow
all right so here we
go
okay
so scripture starts it says in the
beginning god created the heavens and
the earth
now the earth was formless and empty
darkness was over the surface of the
deep and the spirit of god was hovering
over the waters
so
what we have are
first the setup of
one thing which seems to be outside of
the system
but is related actually to the top of
the system so you have god
who is in the beginning the beginning
can be interpreted as the head
the actual word means the head of
something it also means something like
the principle
right the the
or the origin
all of these words work into in the
beginning and so god is in the beginning
and he separates
heaven and earth
and the characteristics he gives of
is
that
because he says that the spirit was
hovering above the water now we have to
see the spirit hovering above the waters
as the repetition you'll see it's all
going to be repetition and showing you
what what the pattern is
and so the spirit hovering above the
water
is
the same as heaven heaven is just wind
right we have to be immediate about this
heaven is that is are the things that
you can't see like wind you can't see
like your breath you can't see like
speech you can't see all of these things
are are things that you that you can't
see
and then so it separates heaven and
earth two basic principles of reality
the earth is void it's empty
it's silence it's water
and heaven is spirit wind breath and
speech
so at first we basically just have two
categories right the the implications of
these two categories are not going to be
clear right away they're going to start
to manifest themselves but you can
already understand it as something like
spirit and potential or actuality and
potential is actually totally fine to
see it that way dante completely
joins together the aristotelian
categories of actuality and potential
and the in the creation narrative the
idea of heaven and earth as these two
basic principles um and so this is just
this right it's it's it's no different
it's a universal category it's there in
every culture that exists this idea of
this basic separation of heaven and
earth and it is completely based on our
actual experience in the world and if
you if you can't kind of re-embody
yourself
and realize that this distinction is a
very
simple and clear one
uh you're going to struggle to
understand what the meaning of it can be
because as you're standing there like
imagine yourself standing there on the
ground
right all light comes from above
right wind comes from above the things
that are above are unreachable you can't
touch the stars you can't touch the sky
you can't touch the sun and the moon all
of these things which give you light and
which are the source of wind
invisible movement
think about it that way think of wind as
invisible movement as invisible patterns
of transformation okay seeing that think
of it that way so you have you have all
of this above you
and then below
you have a world that you knock your
foot against you have a world that you
can touch that you can count that you
can that you can get dirty with that can
kill you uh and that is also dark
right it hides the sun if you take
something that's on the ground you take
a rock and you put it above your head
it's gonna hide the light from you
right this is very embody right this is
very very uh but what it does is it
separates two basic categories of
reality
and so when god said let there be light
and there was light god saw that the
light was good and he separated the
light from the darkness god called the
light day and the darkness he called
night there was an evening and there was
a morning the first day
so now it starts to become clear you can
easily understand of course if you can
embody yourself
that light has to do with heaven
has to do with spirit it's above
and then darkness
has something to do with
this void
so you don't necessarily have to
represent it below but it becomes
analogous to below because it's the
moment when
the light stops being
stuck it's the moment where the light
stops showing you what the world is like
so i i'm placing it like this for you to
understand you wouldn't necessarily have
to put knight at the at the bottom but
this is a good way to kind of see light
dark uh earth as void and empty
and heaven as wind spirit breath
and speech
so god
sorry let me say
so god is above
and he speaks
and light comes down
on on the world
so then god says let there be a vault
between the waters to separate
water from water so god made the vault
and separated the water under the vault
from the water above it and so it was so
god called the vault sky and there was
an evening and there was a morning the
second day
all right
so already you're starting to see
something like a narrowing
you have heaven above but now you have
like a second heaven which is like okay
what's going on
you have the water that is below it's
kind of split into the potential the
earth that is below is kind of opened up
and now we have
a pattern which is similar
which is setting itself up inside the
world
so there's
you're going to start to see that this
pattern of attention is fractal just
like
the way in which multiplicity moves into
unity in any object in the world or in
any community in the world
happens at every level of reality
and this is what is going to start to
appear to you is that the pattern just
repeating itself at different levels
until it comes together in the middle
okay
um
and so we have these waters being
separated and then we have now a
secondary heaven another heaven which is
also above
but it's something like inside the earth
the earth now is is obviously not the
earth exactly the way that we understand
it but at the inside the things that are
visible
and have are quantifiable
now
augustine said this clearly he said he
said everything you see and when you
look up in the sky all the things you
see the sun the cloud the stars all of
this is the earth
all of this because it can be quantified
but it the the second heaven those
things above that actually can be seen
and identified
they are like a secondary heaven there
are pointers
towards
something which is truly invisible you
could say or patterns that are truly
invisible
so the
i mean it's it it's not it's not uh i
don't want you to think that i'm being
all esoteric here right it's like the
world has a pattern
let's say
day and night that's a pattern and the
way the thing that manifests that to you
that you can recognize it is a pattern
is those shining lights up in the sky
that move
right these shining lights up in the sky
they move
and they reveal to you
a regular pattern
the regular patterns of reality are in
the sky
the irregular the more embodied
irregular patterns are in the world
they're still there but they're more
irregular but the ones in this heavens
are regular right every day the sun
comes up every day this the the sun goes
down the moon has its phases the stars
move in the sky and so it's it's it's
completely natural that these heavenly
bodies
are pointers to pattern they point us to
patterns they point us to
the invisible patterns you could say
even though they are obviously visible
okay
so god said let the water under the sky
be gathered to one place and let the dry
ground appear and it was so
so god called the dry ground land and
gathered the water and the gathered
water waters he called seas
and god saw that it was good
now i wanted i want to point you here
something that i haven't pointed to yet
before so
now think of the think of the the
problem of intelligence that i'm trying
to present to you and it's kind of
embodied or
active participation in the way that
reality manifests itself to you
teleologically
so god says
and you can imagine it like god says is
god shining light okay
so imagine an eye in the sky
and that
a sun and i the sun is the same thing as
an eye let's say and this is shining
light down on the world
and he's showing you things
and that has to do with identifying
so
when you encounter something that you've
never seen before
and you see it what is it that you want
to do
you want to identify it
that's your job your job is to identify
if you don't identify it you don't know
if it can kill you you don't know if
it's dangerous you have no idea
and so there's a direct relationship
between
seeing
speaking in the sense of identifying
naming you could say okay and so god so
so god
speaks
identifies as light comes down from
heaven manifest itself on the thing
and then god speaks it into being
but then
he
sees its relevance he recognizes
that which is manifesting itself to him
and he says that it's good he judges it
right away god judges
now think of your think again of your
experience think of your just basic
experience right you walk in to the room
you see the glass
you identify it
and immediately you ask yourself
consciously or unconsciously you're
always asking yourself if it's good
this is necessary
because the reason why you even perceive
the glass in the first place is because
you use it to drink water
and so you always have to ask yourself
if it's good or not
is it a good glass
and this is this is true about
everything that you encounter you don't
even do it consciously this is true of
everything you encounter as you're
walking on the grass
you're you have a system which is
constantly judging
because it has to be able to recognize
if there's a hole it has to be able to
recognize that there's an object in your
way and so it's looking at the ground at
the grass that you're walking on or the
path and it's always identifying
naming
and recognizing
whether it's good
so hopefully this makes sense
all right
so now we're really going to start to
see
this fractal pattern start to appear
more clearly
so you have the basic structure you have
the the very invisible patterns of head
principle origin wind spirit breath
speech which is completely above
and now you have the void empty silent
question puzzle
darkness
potential
all of this is below
and now at every level of reality
this is going to start to appear as
being the same pattern and so like i
said the the
the potential and the actuality of the
glass is relative obviously
but it points to some to the pattern
itself to the pattern of
the of identity and potentiality itself
and so this is why you're going to see
at every level it's going to repeat
so you have the secondary heavens
which are the sky and then you have the
secondary earth
and now in the secondary earth the same
pattern happens again so god creates dry
ground
and separates it from the waters
so dry ground is
above
it's higher than water right this is
just basic experience
dry ground is higher than water dry
ground is the place where you live dry
ground is the place where you find
meaning
because that's where you build cities
that's where you do things that's where
you eat all of this like is from the dry
ground that's where you can breathe air
you can encounter spirit
from the dry ground
and light
but you can't in the sea right and the
sea if you stay there too long you die
because you run out of spirit you run
out of meaning you run out of air all of
these analogies play themselves out um
so imagine dry ground as a mountain is
the best way to understand it you have
this mountain and then at the bottom of
the mountain around the mountain you
have the sea
which is an image of the original chaos
the original potentiality now at a
different level
then god said let the land produce
vegetation seed bearing plants and trees
on the land that bear fruit with seed in
it according to the various kinds and it
was so the land produced vegetation
plants
bearing seeds according to their kinds
and trees bearing fruit with seed in
accordance to their kinds and god saw
that it was good and there was an
evening and there was a morning the
third day now here notice again what is
going on right
so god says let the land produce
vegetation but not just produce
vegetation what is he saying he's saying
produce
seed bearing plants why seed bearing
plants what a strange thing to say
he's saying
seed bearing plants
because once again
in this pattern now
the seed
is the identity
and the vegetation
is the variation or is the bottom part
of this pattern so he's repeating the
pattern he's saying
you need a way for this identity to
recognize the identity of the plant
that's the seed the seed is
the manner in which you recognize
the identity of what you're encountering
so you want reality
to have stability
this is how we work in the world we have
to be able to recognize the different
plants
and in that pattern what there is is
there's both identity
and variability so we're moving towards
the kind of multiplication but this
multiplication always has to be
a recognition also of the identity of
each plant and how these plants are
different from each other
and and and how they participate in a
major pattern of just plants um so you
can see this fractal this fractal
process just kind of continuing then
once again
uh the same thing god says the identity
is in the god said it's in the seed of
the plants and then the plants kind of
manifest his variability god sees and
judges and says
that it is good
so now you can see uh
same thing the dry ground on the dry
ground you have the same pattern of
above and below right identity spirit
obviously it's not spirit in this case
but identity and variability all right
so we continue
so god said let there be lights in the
vault of the sky to separate the day
from the night and let them serve
as signs
to mark sacred times and days and years
and let them be lights in the vault of
the sky to give light on the earth and
it was so
god made two great lights the greater
light to govern the day and the lesser
light to govern the night he also made
the stars god set them in the vault of
the sky to give light on the earth
to govern the day and the night and to
separate light from darkness and god saw
that it was good and there was an
evening and there was a morning the
first the fourth day
so now in the heaven even in the world
of meaning
the same pattern appears so the pattern
appears below in kind of the world of
manifestation you could say as a fractal
pattern but it also appears above
in the pattern itself
and so we have these signs in the sky
they are signs to mark the days there
are signs for you to identify
the pattern of reality
and there's one of the major ones one of
the major uh lights which is there to
govern the day and when to govern the
night so you have light and dark
even in the heavens
the pattern is fractal all the way
through right every day is going to be
like that just spoiler here
and god said let the water team with
living creatures and let birds fly above
the earth across the vault of the sky so
god created the great creatures of the
sea
sea monsters it doesn't say they don't
like to say sea monsters but great
creatures of the sea mean sea serpents
and sea monsters
that all these demythologies the
mythologizing uh biblicists are the
worst
it just means it means sea monsters um
god created the great creatures of the
sea and every living thing with which
the water teams that moved about it
according to their kinds and every
winged bird according to its kind and
god said saw that it was good god
blessed them and said be fruitful and
increase in number and fill the water in
the seas and that the birds increase on
the earth there's an evening and there's
morning the fifth day now this is where
you're gonna start to see what's really
going on because until now you might
have thought that what i'm saying is
just a bunch of like just random
interpretation but here you it it
becomes impossible not to see why on
earth would god create birds and fish on
the same day
what is happening it's the strangest
thing in the world it seems to us
doesn't make any sense right well it
only makes sense if we understand that
he's constantly establishing the
repetition of the heaven and earth
pattern of the above and below pattern
which is started from the beginning
and so he puts he creates the birds
above and this and the sea monsters
below and the fish so even in the sea he
separates fish and sea monsters
the fish are those that you can eat that
you can encounter and the sea monsters
are those that are going to eat you
right there's a difference between the
two
so you have the fish and the sea
monsters but even in this whole pattern
you have the birds
and the fish as framing again the same
duality which is being framed from the
very beginning of the of the text
and you have to understand that that's
what's been going on from the beginning
because why would god create vegetation
before he created the sun and the moon
it doesn't make any sense in terms of
science how can you create vegetation
first and then create the sun
it is completely illogical in terms of a
scientist but in terms of a pattern of
reality
it's completely understandable
and what you'll notice is that
from the beginning of this whole thing
the bottom stuff appears first
the potentiality kind of manifests
itself
first
as a question as this kind of darkness
which is calling to be solved this
potential which is asking to be resolved
and then comes the answer from above
right the the the name the idea the
light so think again about your
experience right you encounter something
in the world you can imagine in a
microsecond
in a micro microsecond the first thing
it does is present itself to you as
potential or as puzzled
and then in obviously it happens almost
simultaneously you immediately identify
judge and make it participate
in reality but you can obviously
have the experience of seeing something
you've never seen before
i mean everybody's had that experience
you see something or you experience
something that you've never seen before
so at first it presents itself to you as
a as the puzzle right it's like what is
this
and then the process has to happen this
back and forth process of question and
identification of question and judging
in order for you to to uh finally be
able to kind of identify and participate
in in its existence
all right
and so now we have god said let the land
produce living creatures according to
their kinds the livestock the creatures
that move along the ground and the wild
animals each according to its kind and
it was so
god made the wild animals according to
their kinds the livestock according to
the kinds and all the creatures that
move along the ground according to their
kinds and god saw that it was good
and so once again
what is happening
what is happening in this in this this
text why
is it that god separates
living creatures
between
livestock
wild animals
and creatures that move on the ground
and the answer is it's very simple it's
just to continue the very same pattern
this hierarchy that we're seeing
is a hierarchy of meaning
right it's a hierarchy of
identification participation in reality
and so when god creates the animals
he part he does it in the same
in the same pattern
that is you have livestock
livestock is more intelligent animals
you can call them animals that are
closer to us
animals that participate in our
intelligence they're they are
the sheep the cows all the animals that
kind of uh let's say are almost not
almost but are more like extensions of
human society
and
then you have the wild animals which are
out there in the chaos in the in the in
the wild in the world that doesn't
completely make sense to us
and now then the creepy crawlers
are the ones that live underground like
the sea monsters live on the ground that
dig holes in the ground that come up you
know and uh and that don't actually are
not completely in the light you could
say that they are actually hiding in
darkness hiding under rocks and so you
have to kind of dig in order to
encounter them you know just like the
sea monsters are and the fish are on the
ground just like the very pattern from
the beginning of darkness chaos
uh you know at the bottom and light
meaning
uh at the top
and then of course now we come to man
again then god said let us make mankind
in our image and our likeness so that
they may rule over the fish
in the sea and the birds in the sky over
the livestock and all the wild animals
and over all the creatures that move
along the ground
so why is it that man has to rule
this is like the most politically
incorrect thing that you could say right
what are we talking about
but once you realize
this pattern the pattern of intelligence
it's it has to change the way you see
reality
which is that intelligence is the place
in which reality is
encountered
identified
and also judged
um
and this is going to be a tough pill for
a lot of people to swallow um but at
least try to understand it try to
understand it in this pattern so man has
to rule
because man is an image of god
man is an image of god in the sense that
man is a locust of intelligence and all
the things that god
said all the things that you saw from
the beginning in terms of how god
creates the world is something that we
participate in to a lower at a lower
level we could say we recognize that we
participate in that at a lower level
because we do that we cast light we
identify
we we judge uh and then and then we we
are the we are the place in which
meaning is gathered into into us
and so now god puts man above all the
creatures which are below now remember
those creatures were already organized
in this hierarchy of
meaning right livestock wild animals
crawlers fish sea monsters all of this
is organized in this kind of hierarchy
of meaning this hierarchy of danger uh
this hierarchy between
that which is in the light which is
identifiable which participates
intelligence and that which is
below and is in the chaos and is and is
also dangerous to you okay
um
and so we have the human person
meeting in the middle becoming the place
where all of these patterns kind of join
together
in the center
and so then to understand the role of
man a little better we actually have to
go into genesis 2 just for a little bit
to kind of understand because in genesis
2 there's another creation narrative
which focuses more on the human person
and then it says god uh
sorry let me skip this actually
oh yeah so it's it says that i don't
want i i don't want to run out of time
here uh but he says god bless them and
said be fruitful increase in number fill
the earth and subdue it again this is
going to be difficult but
intelligence
fills the earth and subdues it
not in in a negative sense but in the
sense of identifying right the scientist
that is constantly discovering new uh
species and all of this is something
like intelligence or man filling the
earth
and subduing it in the sense of
identifying it and making it participate
in a pattern of meaning rule over the
fish in the sea and the bird in the sky
and over every living creature that
moved in the ground
then god said i give you every
seed bearing plant
et cetera et cetera and then
he saw that it was good
and it's important that when god created
the humans he creates the male and
female
and in scripture there's a sense in
which at first this is almost like man
is actually androgynous that he creates
man male and female
that is in man is the duality
of heaven and earth itself
right so there's a
microcosm
of this basic duality of heaven and
earth which is being reproduced inside
the human person
as within them they also contain
this actuality and potentiality and how
they also participate in the manner in
which actuality and potentiality come
together in the world so it's not just
in them but it's actually in in as being
intelligent
uh intelligent uh
subjects they are able to now
encounter the world as this union of of
these two
all right so this is where i wanted to
go into the second chapter of genesis
just for a little bit to help you
understand how this kind of comes
together
so it says this is the account of the
heavens and the earth when they were
created when the lord god made the earth
and the heavens now no shrub had yet
appeared on the earth now you see it's
different here here there is a scent in
which actually man kind of comes before
everything he's actually there at the
outset before god did all those other
things before you can imagine that god
was man or the microcosm or the
intelligent agent was there even in the
origin of creation itself uh no shrub
had yet appeared on the earth and no
plant had sprung up for the lord god had
not set rain on the earth and there was
no one to work the ground but streams
came up from the earth and watered the
whole surface of the ground
then the lord god formed a man from the
dust of the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life and the man
became a living being
so it's a similar image as to what we
have before but here man is there right
at the outset
so it says that there is no plan there
is nothing on the ground and that water
covered the earth
water came out from the earth and
covered the earth so it's the same age
as before you have
heaven above and the earth below the
earth is chaos and water and then what
god does is he gathers all the
potentiality
the dust
all this formless chaos
he gathers it into one place
and then he puts heaven into it
he blows air into this gathered dust
and that's how man becomes a living
being
now
what i want to propose to you
is that process
of gathering dust
and putting air
into it
that's what was being described in the
first chapter of genesis and that is how
you encounter everything in reality
all the time
non-stop
that is the world presents itself to you
as indefinite potential
and the manner in which you are able to
to exist in a living world
is that intelligence gathers potential
into bodies
and then puts
purpose
or recognizes purpose
engages with purpose meaning spirit
breath
and that is how
that is how the world actually exists
right and so the description in genesis
is a description of how the world exists
not in a scientific way
but in a way which takes
into account
that intelligence is necessary that we
are intelligent beings in the world and
that we can avoid that problem we can't
pretend that we're not in the world and
that we're just analyzing phenomena and
that we're not part of that process
so it's a it's a cosmic
vision of reality which includes the
viewer which measures the viewer or
includes the viewer in the way in which
we understand the world
all right until we have this image again
now
we can we can represent it this way
we can also represent it this way
this is a way that will help you
understand if you can realize that you
can represent it this way you're going
to understand so much and this is where
i want to make a shameless plug which is
that my brother um
and i we developed a lot of this way of
speaking about reality together which i
which is not something that we invented
it really is just a reinterpretation of
traditional pattern making its
interpretation of the church fathers of
the rabbis of the of the brahmin of it's
it's just a
way in which we're trying to represent
these traditional uh stories um
for the modern world he wrote a book
called the language of creation which
goes through a lot of the things that
i'm talking about in almost in a more
even in a more kind of mathematical
technical way um so now think of think
of this
the first image that i showed you as
heaven and earth you could say
so this is the same
so at the top you have i'm just lay them
out there like there's more complexity
to this but it's like father heaven
spirit light essence pattern mind
purpose all of these things which are
above
and then at the bottom mother earth
waters chaos potential question
body
uh
puzzle
um multiplication all of these images of
that which is uh below
and then what you have is you have
the pattern which descends right the ray
of light the speech
the speaking which comes down right the
logos which comes down from the father
and connects with heaven
right
sorry connects with earth
and that usually in in all traditions
pretty much appears at the top of a
mountain which is just completely uh
completely uh intuitive right the
mountain is the place where heaven and
earth meet it's like the earth kind of
coming together into a point
where
the heaven now touches
the earth at it at its highest point
okay but it's also an image of this
difference between quality and quantity
identity variability you know all of
this kind of image of uh
of the relationship between
the identity of your team
and the variability of its players of
its idiosyncrasies all of that will kind
of come down below as this image of the
mountain um or
the the pyramid
and so i won't go into it to this right
now but there are there's a century
there's let's say a
centrifugal
force and a centripetal force that is
there is there is a capacity to move
into attention
to move into identity to move into
purpose
and then there's a way in which we are
able to kind of have this
let's say
what you could call a breakdown of
attention or focused attention but it's
also this kind of
general attention you could call it
where we're
we have this general attention on the on
the borders of our even of our visual
field where it's like almost like an
alarm system right where things things
we don't have a lot of a lot of energy
there but if things pop in
this variability kind of pops in on the
edge and it's the question right the
puzzle something's happening here and i
can't see it it's a puzzle so what do i
do i then put my attention on it
identify it judge it and do all the
things that we talked about before um
and so there's there's a there's a
centrifugal force and a centripetal
force and that's true as much as you're
in your attention as it is in a team or
a country or any group anything that has
body
there's something which is making it
more towards its identity and some
aspect which is pushing it towards
multiplicity variability uh and
potentiality okay i don't want to go
into that too much because that would
take us into a whole other other world
but just to understand that you you
probably are if you're unions you're
aware of the kind of coagula solve
structure that jung used in terms of
alchemy this is exactly what i'm talking
about right this is exactly the coagula
solved pattern which is a movement
towards solidity and identity and then a
dispersion into uh into potentiality
but what i want to help you to
understand especially is that this
structure like this basic pattern can
help you understand
so many things right it's it's the
pattern of a temple
right
it's a it's a pattern of a temple where
in the temple let's say in the in the
jewish temple you had the holy of holies
where the where the glory of god would
descend in the holy of holies
and then there you would have a priest
who was just one person
and then outside of that you would have
all these levels of quantification
where outside you would have the
priestly cast then you would have the
faithful and then you would have the
strangers
right it's a pattern of a church which
has the same pattern you have the altar
in the highest point of the church where
god descends on the altar and then
there's also a
a reduced amount of people that are
there that represent this moving into
quality this moving away from quantity
and then the sacraments get dispersed
out into the nave where the faithful
gather
and then there's a narthex or a
vestibule where
strangers come and then on the outside
of the church there are gargoyles and
strangers and other aspects of reality
okay um so this is the structure of
the structure of of the way that greeks
understood themselves in ancient times
right they had the umphalos they had the
they had the navel of the world
and in that place they received oracles
from heaven
which would which would bind them
together which would manifest their
destiny all of that was manifested at
the place where they had the the
belly button of the world the center of
the world and then as you moved away you
would have greeks and then
strangers that you knew
and then finally barbarians and
ultimately
monsters
things that have confused identities
things that you don't recognize would be
outside on the outer edges of this okay
um
so like i said this is basically just
the pattern of of the way in which we
encounter the world but it's also the
pattern of
the pattern of how society is actually
bind together it's it's not just it's
not just a subjective subjective
experience but it scales up in terms of
your experience into the social uh
experience uh and ultimately i think
into a cosmic
version it's an image of the cosmic of
the cosmic pattern um so i just want to
show you quickly without even going into
detail i want to show you how this
pattern just appears
everywhere so here's an icon of the
ascension of christ look you have above
you have the top of the pyramid or the
top of the mountain you have the
principle the logos which is above
uh you can imagine that the father is
actually above this hidden above and
then below you have the mother as the
place of potentiality and then next to
her you have all this multiplicity so
you have the one you have the mother you
have the twelve okay this is one example
here's an example of the image of
baptism
so you have
christ as the one who now joins heaven
and earth as this point at the top of
the mount the joints have been entered
but now he's descending all the way down
from the top let's say down into the
waters
down into the waters of chaos and you
see the spirits above which is coming
down on the on on the top of the
mountain and below you have the sea
monsters which are below in the chaos of
the waters
right
symbol just many many and so this is a
version that i made which i call the
image of everything basically
and it's just trying to kind of capture
the bible story as an image of this this
pattern
as an image of what how the the top of
the pattern relates to the bottom of the
pattern the waters at the bottom the the
sin the fall you know the thorns as this
multiplicity
um et cetera et cetera the sea monster
uh i don't want to interpret it but
there are different ways in which you
can you can kind of see this um
and the last one i wanted to show you is
an image of the last judgment uh which
is really
the ultimate image of this if you want
to see an ultimate image of this whole
pattern because obviously the last
judgment being the last moment or the
eschaton or the moment in which all the
totality is manifested in one final
thing then you have this image of
of the world
in this version especially you actually
have the father above above right at the
top
um
can you i don't think you can see my
cursor oh
can you see my cursor
oh here you can see it this way okay so
you have the father above here
then you have the logos descending onto
the world can you see that he's got the
world underneath him
and then you have
that which is below
which is both
the hell
this kind of monstrous hell
okay
but it's also the place of
paradise here
because it's the place in which we
gather things together
so remember in scripture the gathering
of the dust and the blowing of the
spirit well that also happens from the
bottom right it's at the so you have the
two sides remember i talked about the
centrifugal and the centripetal force
on the left of christ is the sword and
there's a descent
down into death
on the right of christ there is his hand
lifting up right lip sorry wrong hand
lifting up
and here you find the gathering of the
saints
and they rise up see these little saints
with angel with wings they go up
on the right of christ
into
glory
so there are very very mysterious things
about this image that i don't want to go
into too much detail
but you can understand that this is
happening through these angels that are
making music
that are making sounds pattern sounds
and this is what is calling to the end
bringing about the judgment of all of
reality in which all of this is kind of
happening the judging of the good
bringing into the center and the the the
ultimate exclusion in a cosmic way
towards towards death
um and then here
this is the process
so this is uh
it's a it's a complicated thing in
orthodox uh theology but on this this is
the soul which is you can see the soul
here the soul is moving up this serpent
slash ladder
so it's both a way to go down and a way
to go up just like shoots and ladders
guys this shoots and ladders is one of
the oldest games in reality it's it's
like it's a truly cosmic game by the way
uh it's almost religious as a game so
you have this coming down and moving up
which is which is captured in one image
and on this are all the sins
that you can have those sins are coupled
with virtues and so as the soul ascends
this thing
they encounter at every level of reality
a demon which is pulling it down but
also they also encounter angels which
are pulling them up
here in this one you don't see the
angels so much um
in other versions you see
in other versions you'll see the angel
like in this one you see the angel as
the one trying to push down the demon
and as you move up you kind of move
towards this this judgment and that's
actually that hierarchy that i showed
you at the beginning in the creation
that also obviously has
a um an analogous version of that in you
in your virtues in your capacity
to scatter yourself into chaos right by
falling into all these thoughts that rip
you apart
and the capacity to join together into
one and to move up the ladder of
attention as you worship god of
attention as you move towards virtue
rather than this dilapidation and
distraction by which you lose
the worship you lose the capacity to
attend to that which is above you and
you fall into chaos and uh
and the multiplicity of the passions
right rip passions that rip you apart
right jordan i think we're starting with
your questions let's go for it
well
how about sub do
think of the word
sub
to or to arrange hierarchically do
to give everything it's due
that is so when man subdues the world he
does exactly what you're doing
right everything is place and that's a
reflection of the
simultaneous
act of perception and judgment and the
fact that those things as you pointed
out are inextricable and that's
technically true right yeah people
psychologists studying perception from
the biological
ground have drawn that inescapable
conclusion
so that was really cool
ritual encounters with other people
in dostoevsky's the devils the possessed
there's a great scene where stavrogun
goes into a
an officer's club and he's coming
unglued at this point in his
political chaos utopian political chaos
he's possessed by these ideas he puts
his fingers in the nostrils of an
ancient general and drags him onto the
street and it just causes absolute chaos
in the entire society
so yeah you realize how fragile like how
easy it is to actually just shatter you
know these this ritual uh virtual
reality yes
dostoevsky understood that so deeply so
that's stunning
the
the female potential
equation i've been criticized a lot for
associating femininity with chaos
although it's not an insult and it's not
something that i did casually and it's
not something i did
and the idea of the seminal word is
precisely a reflection of that and and
the implication of that is feminine
potentiality and the
analog between the word and
the drawing out of potential new forms
so there's a sexual element to that
obviously that's reflected in the idea
of the seminal word
the pyramid notion
on top of the uh
that george washington
aluminum of all things because aluminum
was the most valuable metal at that
point and so that idea that there's a
an a
pure and valuable
talk to the pyramidal structure
like that's an icon of the entire
structure of the united states and by by
extension the entire let's say western
world but world as such yeah the
egyptian pyramids were most probably
capped with gold like the very top of
the pyramid would be like a mini pyramid
and then that would have been uh gilded
right so one of the advantages to the
interpretive framework this interpretive
framework is that it explains the
intrinsic sacred nature of the pyramidal
structure
it's a great mystery like what's up with
these pyramids exactly and like people
put a lot of work into those things so
it wasn't trivial yeah and the ziggurats
are pyramids too people always want to
separate them but you know all these
structures these kind of these
structures that are representing
mountains are like geometric versions of
mountains uh that's what they are and if
you under once you understand that then
you realize that every time someone goes
up a mountain in scripture
it's it's the same as a pyramid it's
going up to the top of reality i think
you did a brilliant job of explaining
that with your analysis of those images
at the at the end are you going to make
that
image you made into a carving
yes i am but it just in line somewhere
in one of my carvings someone someone is
like you need a client to purchase that
i have one but i can also make one for
you if you want it's quite something
jonathan and then this last thing i'll
say i think is
um
in the second creation version
where you have man primary
that's a
analog a repetition of the notion of the
word
yeah so it's the same so that so
interesting seeing that embedded in in a
really archaic narrative there oh so i
do have one other thing
why did you use intelligence as as the
as the primary descriptor of the
interactive consciousness instead of
logos
well it the reason why i mean i tried to
kind of move between the two it's also
because it's hard to you to know which
word to use uh because the way that the
ancients understood intelligence was
very it's a little different from the
way we understand it it was more it was
a it's called a noose in orthodox
thinking which is it's actually it's
beyond rationality it's the capacity to
directly grasp
the pattern
exactly that's why it's related to
attention yeah yeah that's yeah that and
that supersedes rationality is embedded
inside that capacity to pay attention
because attention selects the objects
that rationality deals with and
rationality tends not to notice that
it's like well that's the easy part it's
like no no no that's that's the hard
part actually
yeah and as we see like
youtube virality is a great way to
understand what happens when we're not
careful about that because what we have
with youtube virality or just internet
virality are just these random you know
stupid things that pop up gather all the
attention vanish pop up gather all the
attention vanish and so it's actually uh
it's actually it ends up being a form of
breakdown of attention it's a
distraction it it prevents us from
seeing
it it's the incapacity to pay attention
to the right things and it leads us into
uh into a kind of breakdown
it was great
i really i always learn a lot listening
to you it's really good
pretty good thanks i really appreciate
it thank you so much
thanks
okay one question someone is asking
could you elaborate on what you mean
about above and below
um well the idea of above and below it
like i said it manifests itself
fractally but it you it's about
something like i mean it's actual and
potential and so it's identity and
potentiality
um and so think about it let's let's
think about it just like let's bring it
down to like a real real like a basic uh
basic level
um
so let's think of a of a sports team
again right so you have the identity
of the sports team the reason why it
exists which is to win basketball games
or to to do that then there's the
identity of the team itself
you know which is kind of embedded in
that and then there's the potential the
potential of that team are the players
they're they're those players have also
their own potential like it's like i
said it's fractal so the players can
change
but the identity of the team won't
so that's what we mean by potential
right and so you can
it's it's variability which comes
together
and then is able to manifest the purpose
in the world
so that's what we mean by above and
below
and so god says um
to let the earth bring forth
that vegetation that has seed
we always forget that god doesn't just
speak it into existence
he says to the earth bring forth
right and so it's like out of the
potential comes this variability
which then receives name from above
and joins it together into specific
identities
and so so like i said this idea of above
and below can be seen in any anything
that you encounter
another question is
you mentioned the pattern of livestock
and wild animals that manifest heaven
and earth are people that try to tame
animals such as tigers bears
examples of breakdown of the pattern and
that is why usually it ends in disaster
definitely i mean you can see that that
you have to kind of have a respect a
subdue as jordan said i love that i
actually love that that is you have to
be able to see things
where they really are and engage with
them where they are in this kind of
pattern of reality and so if you engage
with if you engage with the pattern of
reality in a wrong way
that's you die
and it and it can be it can be something
like taming uh taming a tiger
but it can also be something like eating
rocks
like rocks are not potential that you
have access to to eat
and and and that's true for like an
indefinite amount of things that there
are certain identities which have
certain potentials that are that can
participate in them and if you don't
encounter that properly then you're
going not going to work if you have a
basketball team and you decide to to
fill the basketball team with gerbils
well your basketball team is going to is
going to lose it's not going to exist
and so there this is how this this
this is how it works like in terms of
this idea of subduing right or judging
is is a very good thing it's a necessary
thing because it's how you judge what
potential
is able to join with what identity
okay we have a heretical question
how sure are you about the universality
of heaven and earth distinction
as i know it is symbolic pattern
appearing with the axial age cultures
buddhism christianity socratic greece
islam
animistic culture for example do not
have clear distinction between those two
categories so by extension what makes
you sure that all of this isn't just a
perfect exposition of an axial age mind
how can i say this
now i'm gonna go back into what i'm
saying i'm gonna go back into what i'm
saying which is about embodied reality
people who talk about the actual age and
animistic as if they don't exist in the
world they just i have no i have very
little patience for that
like where are you
where are you to tell me about the
actual age as if it's something which
you're not in and talk about the
animistic age as if it's something that
somehow you can see from outside like
this
how can i say this it's like
we don't know much about animistic
religions because we're not animistic
religions
we're always interpreting animistic
religions from the place where we are
and so it's a very to me it's always
true it's like
do you know the secret traditions of the
shamans
but you read the text that some european
went out into tibet
and wrote some text based on what they
encountered there were you initiated
right did they bring you into the secret
of secrets did they tell you what their
secret traditions are no they didn't you
don't know them and so i'm not saying
that that that the comment is true or
false i'm saying that you really know
less about these traditions than you
think you do
because the way you know about something
is not about it's not by studying it
from the outside
but it's about it's about encountering
it and living it from the inside
um and those that are initiated into the
higher mysteries they're not supposed to
talk about it anyways
so they're not going to tell you
so even if a scholar was
at some point maybe initiated into the
higher mysteries
they shouldn't tell you and if they tell
you it means they probably weren't
initiated and they're bullshitting you
right this is true like even of the
elusian mysteries everybody talks about
the elder scene and mystery as if they
know what they are it's like that was a
pretty awesome thing because no one ever
told anybody
what happened there right
and so it's really important to
understand that
to understand this
anyways i'm sorry i don't want to i
don't want to go off on this person but
it's really just important to understand
the implications
of these embodied patterns um and how it
is that every time we pretend that we
can stand above them and and just
analyze them that we're we're we're i
think we're deluding ourselves um and so
coming back to heaven and earth
um
how can i say this like i think that
heaven and earth is a universal pattern
doesn't mean that there maybe aren't
other ways of explaining that same
duality or that same relationship um
and also it's the same it's the same
it's the same thing like it's the same
problem like these animistic
uh cultures that were there before the
actual age you don't know anything about
them
you you have no way of of encountering
them and and the ones you encounter now
the idea that they're the same as the
ones that were there before the actual
ages also it's all kind of weird
scientific delusions people give
themselves
sorry
sorry to ever ask that question i didn't
mean to kind of go off but these are
sometimes these things i i get itchy
about them
okay someone is asking
what is the meaning of the god calling
the human very good versus calling the
other things only good
and that's very it's super interesting
because there's even a there's even a
day where god doesn't say that it was
good by the way people always forget
that
when god separates the waters he doesn't
say that it was good uh and so i mean i
think that's what it is it's that in a
way the human being
participates in the pattern of the good
in this way similar to the way god
that is the human being can do good and
can recognize good right and can
participate in the good
uh whereas the other beings
less so not completely
not completely uh
absent of it but less so and so i think
that all living creatures participate in
the good and participating god
ultimately but it's just it's just a
question of hierarchy and embedded
embedded patterns you could say
there's a psychological observation
in terms of psychological work how out
of the infinite complexity of
interpretations
certain interpretations of experience
have been offered to us to stay inside
the group we accept defensively versus
how can
how we can seek out our intuitive other
patterns in our experience create a new
reality for ourselves
okay
i would say
let's let's let's see this way that
the patterns of specific groups
they are always limited
they're limited by their limitations
they're limited by the fact that they
embody the patterns in a specific
context so because they do so they will
always be somewhat faulty they won't be
perfect because they're not right they
they're they're they're somewhat lower
on the mountain of meaning you could say
and so
but
ultimately if you're attentive the idea
is that within those smaller patterns
you're able to intuit higher patterns
and also and hopefully participate in
things which lead you into higher
patterns so if you're let's give you an
example like if
if you're part of a group of of uh of uh
addicts let's say right you hang out
with a bunch of cokeheads or people who
take heroin so obviously you're in a
there's something in that pattern which
is true
right there's something in that pattern
which binds you together in a way
towards the telos towards the reason but
there's also something in that pattern
which is
leading you into a breakdown of yourself
but it still has something
and so hopefully that's something right
that capacity to bind together with
others in a kind of communion
that is ultimately what should lead you
up towards a better version of that
pattern
right towards instead of hanging out
with a bunch of coke heads right you
hang out with some people who play
sports or hang out with people who are
interested in cars or people are
interested in this but there is a way in
which even in the lowest versions of
these there's always something for it to
even exist that has to kind of
participate now
i would be wary about the danger of
thinking
the danger of seeing novelty as a value
in itself
because this is something which we've
seen very very much
in the modern world which is we value
novelty as a
novelty is
novelty is uh neutral
right some novelties are good and some
novelties are bad
and so we shouldn't seek out
new patterns
just because they're new
if we seek new patterns or better
patterns it's because they're better
better in the sense that they they bring
us closer to something which is a
healthy mixture of this
healthy balance of the patterning and
the multiplicity right it's this
incarnational principle
if you kind of if you're not careful
it's true you can move too high and go
into tyrannical systems if you move too
low then you fall into kind of anarchic
chaotic chaotic realities
someone is commenting that
your proposition at the beginning of the
talk that intelligence is necessary for
the world to unfold reminds them of
young recounting in memory dreams
reflection standing over an african
vista and having the feeling he's the
but first consciousness to ever have
witnessed such a thing
yeah
i mean there's definitely
there's a there's an aspect of potential
uh or encountering the strange which is
which is very important because it
there's an aspect of um
surprise and wonder which comes with
encountering that which we don't know uh
which is also part of the
the pattern of reality and so there's an
idea right in ancient stories that
there are treasures hidden in the deep
right that there are treasures hidden in
the outside their treasures being
guarded by monsters and so there's a
sense in which moving out into
potentiality
is also a way in which to kind of
discover
these these pearls right these secrets
these precious stones these gems that
are kind of hidden in in the unknown so
that's definitely part of the pattern as
well
yeah i think we have another question by
jordan
actually it's a question from tammy so
i'll let her ask it
this question
how did darwin
bring plato back
because by coming back into the world of
biology
he inevitably brought back purpose
driven action or selection is the best
way to to understand it right he brought
back the idea of selection and selection
is not chaos right selection is not
random selection is is purpose oriented
and it's purpose oriented towards
the perpetuation of the seed the
perpetuation of the identity and so
this is the argument that i've been
trying to put forth with sam harris and
richard dawkins it's like you guys
there's a big contradiction here between
darwin and newton or the way we look at
newton it's like this is a big problem
and so it's a surprise it's like it's a
it's a surprise i think that nobody kind
of expected and nobody necessarily
framed it completely that way but it
they did end up bringing back
uh the idea of quality
back into the back into the picture
right because you you choose for a
reason and the reason is something which
is closer to your own the perpetuation
of your own identity
and it's like crafted by evolutionary
forces and so meaning itself is the
consequence of the evolutionary process
and how that tangles up with the
like the theological perspective that
you've brought to bear today that's an
incredibly complicated and difficult
problem but as you said god calls the
earth to manifest its potential
so
yeah and so you could you could
how can i say this it's like so you can
see it bottom up which is i mean i've
been experienced i've been expressing it
more bottom-up recently just because
people are are kind of scientists
scientifically mind
but you can also you can say it
completely top-down like you can see it
as
like like i was trying to explain to you
these
the evolutionary process of maintaining
your identity
is is a reflection of a deeper
pattern
which is a cosmic pattern of how
the world actually unfolds so it's not
that it's not necessarily that
evolutionary process
brought about this
it's that the reason why evolutionary
processes
work the way they do and do what they do
is because they're they're
functioning within a larger system
they're imaging they're manifesting the
way the world works so that's how the
world discussion of subdue starts to
become so relevant because as creatures
make their choices and live or die by
them what they are in fact doing is the
spiritual process of subduing and if
they do it improperly then they perish
yeah exactly and so so there's an image
like we were talking about the idea of
man at the outset you know and so this
is this is represented in iconography
for example as the image of of christ
jesus christ human jesus christ is
creating the world which is just like
for people it just freaks them out
because like how does this work how is
this possible but that's that's the
that's the that's the understanding
there is a manner in which
you how can i say this and there's a
manner in which
just like we have this christian idea
that christ acts as an axis which
transforms the past and the present
let's say which kind of acts as this
this central axis you could say that
intelligence as it manifests itself in
the world does the same
that is the human person
human intelligence
goes back into the past and makes sense
of it and goes into the future and makes
sense of it and so you could say that
intelligence is at the outset
the things don't exist outside of this
this capacity to contain them in
consciousness and so conscious so the
world is is born in consciousness
and the past is well the past is born in
consciousness too
so all those those processes that people
try to understand all these all the big
bang and all this stuff
it's still born in man like it's still
born in consciousness
so the real origin
is not the big bang
this is going to be the weirdest thing
you're going to understand the real
origin is the intelligence
which is able to even perceive the big
bang or see it as a pattern as as not
just a quantum field which never changes
it's like
perceiving change transformation
identity participating it
like that's the origin of reality so the
description in genesis is like i'm
trying to help you see that it is an
actual description
of the origin of the world
it's not a metaphor like in the way that
we want to think about it it's not just
a fairy tale which is helping us
understand things we don't understand it
is describing the manner in which
reality originates
and it originates in meaning
then phenomena not phenomena
phenomena first as a puzzle right right
i talked about that like this potential
that bubbles up and calls to be answered
and then meaning which comes down so you
can see the same from every single all
scientific theory is like that it's like
something presents itself as a puzzle
and you're like what is that and then
here comes the logos the seed which
comes in and patterns it or identifies
it judges it separates it from other
things in the way that happens in the
first chapter of genesis
okay there's two more psychological
questions i'm going to
tell them both together because i think
their length
and jordan you may also have something
to contribute to that one
how would you work with the problem of
inclusive exclusive categories in these
times
projection scapegoating
and the other question that's i think is
related
where do the movements of cancer culture
or black lives matter fit or how to make
sense of these movements into this
intelligence model
yeah
so one of the things one of the things
we're seeing is we're seeing we're
seeing out of control versions of this
identification system or the system of
communion
the way in which reality works is
fractal and so
communities or identities embed
themselves in each other that's how
that's how it works and so in a in a
normal kind of traditional world
you can be a family
in a neighborhood in a community
right in a nation in a church
and it's like it's all embedded and you
can also participate in all these
different identities you can be in a
club or you can be in this and that and
so it all kind of works together um so
one of the problems we're having right
now
is that
let's say kind of woke woke culture
has
understood the problem of identity right
they understand they understand the
problem of exclusion but the answer they
give is that they want to account for
everything
they want everything to fit
now the problem is that that doesn't
it's impossible it's an impossible and
it's even a dangerous thing
and there are a lot of ancient
traditions which help you understand
that so for example like you have the
idea in jewish law that you have to
leave a fringe on your vestment
or you have to leave the corners of the
field until
for the
strangers uh
all of these patterns are there to
manifest the fact that
you can't have
a system which is both coherent and
complete at the same time you can't
those two things
well the ziggurat answers that question
too because
people can be included at a higher level
of unity and excluded at a lower and so
part of this is conceptual confusion
it's like the problem of category is the
problem of inclusion and exclusion and
exclusion can lead to demonization very
easily and that's a big problem a
fundamental problem but the the problem
that you're talking about that's
manifesting socially as a as a
consequence of this lack of
understanding of the hierarchy of value
so the the people who are pushing
diversity inclusivity and equity are
saying something like
look we're all divinely human
and you object to that by saying well
yes but we still need to differentiate
ourselves into specialized categories
and we have to think through that very
carefully so that we subdue things
properly
oh exactly and so what what's happened
and so what's happened is that people
want to make
inclusivity
the only
value
really the only value
because of the problem of exclusion and
so
what happens and this is this is
what i'm going to say is is going to be
seem radical to some but what we're
seeing in this process is the actual
destruction of the world and it's
actually going to this type of thinking
will can actually destroy the world or
lead to absolute tyranny one or the
other or maybe one because causing the
other because
so imagine you have
a basketball team right you have a
basketball team the purpose of the team
is to play basketball to win a
championship to do this but then you say
no no no
the the purpose of the team is inclusion
and now imagine you do that for every
single level of reality in every single
communion you say that the purpose of
your group
is inclusion
but so then you sacrifice the actual
purpose of the group which is to play
basketball to win games and everything
for inclusion and you end up doing that
in all aspects of reality what you're
doing is you're devouring the purpose
you're you're eating it it's like it's
becoming eaten by this thing this ink
this it's a monster it's like it's the
potential it's it's like potentiality
isn't is infinite it's like you need to
let all this potential in and so we were
like this is wrong right you're
excluding this potential so we need to
kind of
bring all this potential in so what it
does is it's like a sea monster that
comes up and devours the and devours the
identities um and so either it brings
about a kind of fragmentation and chaos
and breakdown
but often the world can't sustain itself
that way so what it tends to do is it
tends to lead to lead into a kind of
absolute identity and it's weird because
the way it seems to be happening it's
just the strangest thing is that it's
like people are trying to make
inclusivity as the tyrannical system
itself
which is just seems like it's not
possible but that seems to be what's
happening is that inclusivity is going
to turn into tyranny but what's
important is that
that that gesture is going to create
something like
absolute scapegoats
com absolute scapegoats which is that
those that will refuse
to participate in this
highest this weird principle of
inclusivity will be
absolutely excluded it's the only sin um
and it's an unforgivable sin and so
we're moving kind of moving towards that
and it's uh
yeah it's kind of scary to see it to see
it happen
well it's part of
terminologically part of an assault on
the idea of the patriarchy and that
means that it's the salt on the idea of
pyramidal categorization itself
because that's assimilated in the
indiscriminate imagination with
tyranny and the identification of
tyranny with the act of categorization
itself
and so this is a deep struggle right so
if the act of categorization is part of
subduing and that's part of the
manifestation of the word then the
assault on that under the guise of
destruction the patriarchy is an assault
on that principle itself and an
identification of the principle of
discrimination with the principle of
tyranny
yeah
i mean the idea that for example like
the idea that the word discrimination
has become an absolute evil is insane
it's an insane moment because you
discriminate all the time
you're you're constantly discriminating
discriminating is like a normal aspect
of reality which is that you're
constantly judging like you're you're
constantly kind of discriminating
whether or not this piece of paper is
the right one to to to scribble on or to
print on and you're discriminating
whether or not this is the right
keyboard for my computer it's like
you're constantly discriminating uh and
so but the fact that we've even made
that word into
well you all did jonathan that god
himself said that that capacity for
discrimination transformed good into
very good
so think of what an assault on that
means it means an assault on our ability
to distinguish between that which is
higher and that which is lower
god
and so but there's a way in which like
it's important to understand that
there's a way in which
this this system like that especially
especially you see it in many versions
but in the christian system the one i
know the best the way in which she kind
of heals itself or the way in which it
it um
it deals with this problem is that at
the very very top
of the hierarchy
is something like identity
and then right above that identity
is something like sacrifice
that is there's the the pyramid is
canotic it's self-emptying
and so the highest thing
the highest thing is the king
and then the very highest thing is the
martyr
and that's super important it's super
important to understand that and it's
it's actually it's actually uh it's
technically uh accurate right in the
sense that
in order for the leg of a chair
to be part of the
chair it has to sacrifice itself to the
higher purpose it has to
because it can't just be a leg of a
chair it has to participate in the
higher pattern
and so the the highest point of the
pattern is the negation of identity and
this is this is going to be this might
be a little hard for people to kind of
get but it'll help you understand a lot
of christian symbolism the highest point
of identity is negation of identity
but it doesn't the problem is that now
what we have is something like
we don't realize that negation of
identity leads to identity
then there's a
there's an identity going like this and
then there's a negation of identity
below or a breakdown and
and they're confusing the negation of
identity below with the negation of
identity above
which is the the capacity to sacrifice
yourself for a higher good
and the capacity to sacrifice yourself
for your own parts
and so the chair
also has to sacrifice its purity
in order to be able to exist
because all chairs have idiosyncrasies
all chairs have aspects of it that
aren't the pure chair or else the chairs
couldn't exist
and so the identity of things sacrifice
themselves
above they give themselves up right so
imagine
you you burn
you take your best cheap and you give it
up to god right you give it up to you
give it up to god or you die as a martyr
um but then there's also a way in which
that which is above then sacrifices
itself for that which is below so that's
one of the ways in which we kind of um
deal with the problem because it's so
it's not like a kind of nietzsche and
will to power thing it's not at all that
right the the real hierarchy ends in in
self-sacrifice
right that's why the cross is at the top
of the hill right that's why the mystery
at the top of the hill is in in mystical
terms we talk about the divine unknowing
like that that you reach knowledge you
read gnosis and then when you reach the
top hypnosis the next step is unknowing
it's actually a form of divine darkness
that's the highest form of mystical
mystical union and this is how one of
the ways in which these the system can
can balance itself out because it is
true that sometimes we we struggle to
think that the highest thing
is okay let's let's think of it this way
the highest thing of the team is the
quarterback that everybody loves and
everybody worships and it's like yeah
that is the top of the team but it's
only the top of the team when the
quarterback sacrifices himself above
to the purpose of the team and
sacrifices himself below
to make the other team members
participate in the team
if he doesn't do that
then he's not going to be at the top
he's going to be a tyrant he's going to
be he's he's not going to be able to get
the team to go here all of these things
are going to happen um and so this is
something which like i said it's maybe a
bit harder to understand i really didn't
expect to go into this in this
conversation but it might be important
to understand the problem of of identity
and
and how it can be solved let's say
through this through this pattern
okay another question
maybe a big one i don't know if it can
be summarized
what is the intelligence of dreams jung
suggested the dream is the purest
expression of individuating intelligence
this seems at odds with the orthodox
view can the two views be reconciled
it's very difficult uh so the the the
orthodox view or the that say that the
way that their fathers talk about dreams
is that they are
mostly chaos that they're mostly these
lower waters this kind of these these
these these moving waters and you have
to be careful not to
pay too much attention to them
but like i said
so there's an interesting image for
example like let me give you an image uh
that you find in in the revelation
it says in revelation at the end of time
the sea will become like glass
the sea will become like crystal
and so you that's the way you can kind
of understand the purpose of dreams is
that
it's this lower potential that's kind of
bubbling up right and and and so
manifests all your passions all your
desires and it kind of in a kind of wild
way that sometimes is illogical that
it's kind of breakdown of logic but then
once in a while
you could say through
divine providence or through aesthesis
like that is through
like let's say the mystic who will
transform himself and will kind of
reduce their slavery to the passions at
some point this potential
can still itself can become still and
then it becomes a mirror
because it is a mirror in the first
place right it's already a mirror
because that's how that's where reality
comes out of reality kind of comes out
of this potential that's that you know
the earth is pulled out of the waters
all of this is is true and so you can
understand it that way it's like the
chaos and this kind of
kind of madness and chaos on the edge
out of which reality comes you have to
be careful not to pay too much attention
to it because it can can break you down
but once in a while
it becomes this pure mirror and then
that's the vision right that's the
that's the mystics vision that's the
capacity to see reality
clear more clearly than you could ever
could because suddenly
it it it becomes a a mirror for the
highest highest things so it's like
you know i one of the things you might
have seen when you see the pattern of
creation is that
god is going like this right so
the waters the earth and then the grass
the stars and then it's like it's kind
of moving in this way so you can
understand it as these extremes but you
can also understand that the lowest part
can become a mirror for the highest part
in the proper circumstance it can become
like this
um
that's one of the things christ does by
the way christ that's one of the we if
you want to understand the story of
jesus he goes to the bottom of reality
and then kind of transforms it into
glory
um anyway a little tidbit on that
okay i'm aware of the time i'm also
aware we could go on for hours and hours
so jonathan i don't know how you're
doing about time you want to take one
last question i'm fine yeah if you want
i'm totally fine i i went too long in my
presentation anyway so i'm willing to
accept uh more questions
okay if the theological
teleological patterns of being
of being constitute the realm of heaven
what then is the abode of the individual
human soul
in other words
what is the relationship between the
semi-platonic conception you've
presented here and the standard
christian model of heaven as a domain of
souls
and so there's a
they're the same
that is that your soul
is your invisible
part of you it's the it's the pattern
the patterning of your of your being
right that's what your soul is and
there's a way
and this is this there's a way in which
that soul
in in its very center right you could
say that there's there's a more there's
a hierarchy of patterns in you and at
the core of that hierarchy of pattern is
god
i want to tell you
like that that it's the spark of the
divine is at the center of every
individual soul
that's the manner in which we actually
exist is that we contain a spark of
of the divine
and that
as we commune with each other as we love
each other
then we
become this embodied pattern and
the your your individual logos
joins with the divine logos
and becomes the body of christ
and so that's the way that it works and
so you can understand it in different
ways you can understand it as
physically how can i say this that
christ says things like you know you are
you are you are called to be like angels
and he says you are gods
and what he means is that
human beings
can become
patterns
for other human beings
right we become models that's why we
have models we have models because
humans can move up into heaven
we can ascend into heaven
and then we become patterns
for others
and we become patrons for others
so we name a church after someone we
name a city after someone we name we
name things
after people because those beings are
like gods
they become
patterns for the rest of us
and so and that's that's actually how
reality works like we reality doesn't
hold together by ideas
even your nations they don't hold
together by ideal they hold together by
a succession of people who modeled
behavior on which you you base yourself
and some of those rise up very high
and become the patron saints of entire
aspects of reality
and that's how they become like angels
they become gods in the divine council
right they they become co-rulers with
christ
all these things that christ talks about
and and these are things that it can
happen at a very small level right your
own father your own mother can image for
you
how to be like
how to live and how to be
uh and then that can scale up you know
all the way to saint peter and saint
paul or the mother of god or or the the
saints which are venerated as uh
as a as being like in the divine council
thank you so much for a great talk
and jordan and tommy thank you so much
for your participation
yeah this has been great i've i'm really
happy because let me say this is that i
was hoping that this discussion would
push me further
in uh saying things uh in a certain way
and kind of bringing things together and
i'm very grateful because i feel like it
it has and so i appreciate i appreciate
jordan you pushed me and i think the
questions were wonderful and so it's
actually been a great opportunity for
myself to just say okay i'm gonna
try as hard as i can to really
bring this together so thank you
thank you everybody
sorry for those who we didn't have time
to
ask their questions
only some so many questions a little
time
i'll i'll just jump in if if like me you
didn't have a chance to answer to ask a
question maybe you can uh uh attend
another uh jung society of montreal
event and
we'll form our group with our purpose
and continue in this in these rich
worlds
very good
all right thanks everybody
you